seen for the first time since being
detained
in minsk bella russian opposition
journalist roman protesovic
on social media he appears to confess
but his supporters say he was
likely under duress protesovic was the
target of an extraordinary intervention
by belarus on sunday
that has become a full-blown
international crisis
he was traveling on ryanair 4978 from
athens
when the flight was diverted to minsk
from its destination vilnius
belarus says the flight was re-routed
because of a bomb threat
but eu leaders in brussels condemned it
as state-sponsored piracy
they urged protestovich's immediate
release and backed sanctions
against belarus this is an attack
on democracy this is an attack on
freedom of expression
and this is an attack on european
sovereignty
and this outrageous behavior needs a
strong answer
therefore um the european council
decided that there will be additional
sanctions
[Applause]
protest fled belarus after president
alexander lukashenko claimed victory
in last august's disputed presidential
election
the opposition candidate in that
election was also forced to flee into
exile
she called for justice to be served we
have to build a broad coalition of
countries
especially those affected in order to
conduct
a thorough investigation of the incident
it's very important that all
perpetrators are brought to justice
including those alleged secret agents on
the plane
alexander lukashenko has been belarus's
president since 1994
a leader described by some as europe's
last dictator
and a man who has a record of harshly
repressing dissent
he's strongly supported by his ally
russia
we are in favor of assessing the
situation not in a rush but on the basis
of
all the available information
after more than a day of strong words
and furious reactions
eu leaders were united and swift in
their response
whether the punitive measures agreed in
brussels will deter similar actions in
the future from belarus
is unclear as is protessovich's fate
natasha butler al jazeera paris